each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
judy's a professor in the department of
computer science at the University of
Pretoria South Africa or research
interests are programming languages and
distributed systems with Nigel horse
bull she co-edited the i ee proceedings
software special issue on rotor research
that came out in 2003 and i'd like to
acknowledge that Judith has provided a
tremendous amount of support and energy
to the rotor community since 2002
Katherine Berg is a master student at
the University of Pretoria she's been a
research assistant at the University
since 2001 and is currently researching
the field of variability management and
software product line engineering good
afternoon as you really could I have not
nothing really to do with the our router
project I'd research in different area
so I would like to say ahead of time if
you do have any questions please feel
free to contact professor to this Bishop
fire Emma and she'll gladly answer any
questions that you do have okay the
project i will present to you is called
rasca tool which stands for software
construction within rotor as background
software construction recognizes the
importance of choosing the right
programming techniques to achieve
acceptable levels of for example
performance maintainability and
reusability and software development
someone involved in software
construction would be an expert on
alternative constructs provided by
programming languages libraries and
software systems as well as techniques
which which can be employed to render a
huge system understandable the
objectives of the rosca tow system
project were to raise the profile of
rotor as a product by tackling the
documentation of some of rotors
components some of the outputs would
include the documentation and the
assessment of the inside constructs of
this
them some recommendations for new port
of rotor and also cause we project
members as already mentioned professor
judith bishop was the leader she was
assisted but by some postgraduate
students john miller and basil Worrell
they are part of the player research
group which is headed by Professor
Bishop then they were so for a few
fourth-year students from the University
of Pretoria and university of karlsruhe
who also assisted with some of the
project tasks
the main way of trying to get the
project done was to get groups of
students to study and report on the
construction of individual components of
rotor developed the documentation and
make it available online when trying to
document and understand a large system
they realize it would be a considerable
challenge so they decided to ease the
task of tackling rotor students would be
exposed to other systems that were
better known such as the view system
which was written and another wrote a
grant by Professor Bishop and Nigel
professor Nigel horse pool at the
University of Victoria now views is a
vendor-independent extensible windowing
system which basically lets you define
user interfaces using XML
a large part of the project was to
present two new software construction
courses at the University of Pretoria
and South Africa as well as at the
University of culture in Germany in
Pretoria the word software construction
costs presented to fourth year computer
scientists and engineers in from
februari to May and from august to
november in 2004 and at the university
of karlsruhe software construction in
that net environment cause was presented
to third and fourth year computer
scientists from May to July in 2004 some
of the course outline was its met listed
there for example teaching students
about object representation and behavior
multilingual programming the sheets or
CLI initiative and rotor issues of
security documenting large systems these
are just some of the things taught to
the student here are some sample
assignments that students had to hurt
you do throughout the course there to
create sample applications using views
on rotor there to document views and
parts of rotor they had to reflect the
existing systems using aspect
orientation and implement generics in
sample applications here are some
comments of students of what they've
learned during the course some have
learned the importance of documenting
the design choices when developing
software others have gained knowledge in
the.net platform and it's libraries some
were introduced to a whole new
programming paradigm and others have
been introduced to concepts such as
genetics also for the first time while
looking at large systems and trying to
document them in an interest in aspect
orientation emerged students wrote
programs using aspect systems for C
sharp they investigated several c-sharp
aop systems and however many did not
wear
they didn't manage to get it working
they found that the best system was was
cos from the University of Virginia es
is a aspect-oriented extension for
c-sharp some more students comment of
what they thought of the course they
enjoyed hearing about new technologies
they thought was quite fun to have guest
lecturers giving some class some of the
classes they thought it was a very
practical cause it was interesting to
them to learn about aspects and generics
and they also liked learning about that
net in an academic setting with a
critical view on this system and design
choices throughout the project we
collaborated they collaborated with some
other people for example Walter tikki
from the University of Karlsruhe who
initiated the course from the Karlsruhe
University side it was the first net
cause presented at that University and
it was also the first noon on Java
course presented there for quite a while
damien Watkins from Microsoft Research
in Cambridge also gave some guest
lectures Bertrand mayor from ETH in
Zurich spoke on his Eiffel project on
net and Nigel horse poo from the
University of Canada University of
Victoria and Canada who wrote also the
view system and he participated on a
consultative basis some of the project
outcomes were the three software
construction courses were successfully
presented at two universities about
eighty students used an examined rotor
the view system was partially documented
using some of the documentation tools
available and considerable experience
was gained in row two however there was
less of the documentation done then
anticipated some outcomes in terms of
software was a methodology for
retargeting api's was developed a
student project was to port views
using QT to linux and a new system
called mirrors which replied reflection
to create a dynamic version of the view
system on dotnet to now the Morris
system was developed by a third year
student david john miller also a
research assistant at the University of
Pretoria he just last week found out
that he won second prize at the Marxist
of Africa developer competition on.net
to some icon comes in terms of paper
papers there were two paper submitted
and accepted at conferences and one
journal paper they are all sort of based
on the work that has been done on rotor
or in that area his conclusion the rasca
two projects stood up quite a bit of
interest in the use of rotel net
especially amongst the students that
participated in the courses then there
were more software and paper outcomes
than was originally anticipated however
not as much of the documentation of
rotor was done it was aimed for in
future the retargeting projects are
continuing and the courses are being
packaged for reuse at a later stage
thank you like I said any questions
please take it as Professor Bishop you
can get to contact details from me but
they are also available online so thank
you I mean there's a link to the project
page for more information
Oh
look at food you'll have a long secret
yeah let's thank our speakers for this
first session